the collapse of everything
familiar is going to open our hearts
i mean look at what aids has done
look at what our the information we have
about the rainforest or the pictures of
somalia
i mean the most open-hearted of us
open first but before this is over
every one of us will probably bury the
dead
and walk through i mean hell
and it will open the heart it can't fail
to open the heart i mean when a friend
dies in your arms
maybe the first time it doesn't work but
the second the third before
we are going to get it sooner or later
and it's it's bigger than all of us
i mean it's just so big and it's always
been there in miniature in the
phenomenon of our own deaths
but we didn't we don't look at that but
you know
if you will contemplate your own death
your heart will open i mean the truth
that i've learned from psychedelics to
put it into
bumper sticker form if that's the way to
think of it
is uh this is the hardest truth there
is this is the distillation of 50 000
years of
of nomadic hunting and orgies around the
campfire and
rockets to the moon and and the whole
thing
it can be summed up in a single phrase
nothing lasts nothing
lasts everything is changing
into something else heraclitus said this
he said
ponte reyen all flows
we flow into this world we
inhabit it and we move on nothing lasts
not your career not your fortune and
finally not even your own sweet
self everything is replaced
and if we can open ourselves to this
by the heart by the by the mind i mean
there's
all ways then we will find
the dignity to and and this is not about
being born in the generation at the end
of the world this is something that
would have worked at every moment in
history
after all heraclitus lived 2500 years
ago
this is the truth of true maturity
nothing less
i mean every time i i take a trip
or or eat a fine meal or
make love or visit an art gallery i feel
the transience of it and that enriches
it that's the heart
dimension is the poignancy of knowing
that
this too shall pass
this too shall pass you know the
earliest piece of poetry in english
is called dior's lament and it begins
nine winters we out the owl held
merengue bird
that now is gone this too
shall pass was a song sung by a poet
to a king somewhere in in france
in the in the 10th century or something
like that
everything is in transition and
the material body can resists this truth
because the material body understands
that if it passes
then it will be replaced by something
which it can't
imagine and that that triggers
an anxiousness but i think this is what
psychedelics teach
that nothing nothing lasts and if we can
incorporate that and
live it we will live every moment
to its fullest the people who are hiv
positive they get to walk around
with the knowledge that nothing lasts
and in a way they are
privileged because after all any one of
us could be
bitten by a snake today and die or have
a tree fall on us or be run over by a
bus
we would have missed living
in that heartful dimension where you
know
that you too will
move from the scene and make way for
something else
[Music]
you